bonsoir à tous ceux nous sommes le
mercredi 13 juillet vous regardez le 7 8
le journal merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition comme chaque jour
nous revenons sur votre actualité locale
entouré de nous inviter mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction on
commence tout de suite par le sommaire
depuis quelques semaines les candidats
au code de la route peuvent passer leur
examen avec la poste des postiers
agrémenté se charge de l'encadrement
nous sommes allés à bois d'arcy du côté
de la plateforme industrielle courrier
nouveau centre agression et la fusion
entre les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
un sujet qui a fait l'actualité de cette
année 2016 où on est le projet quels
sont les avançons nous ferons pas dans
notre chronique et pour finir des idées
de loisirs pour vos vacances et les agri
vacances et à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet le propose aux adultes et
aux enfants plein d'animations autour
des animaux et de l'agriculture pendant
la saison estivale est depuis le 4
juillet les candidats au code de la
route peuvent passer l'examen dans les
locaux de la poste dans le cadre de la
réforme du permis de conduire inscrite
dans la loi du 6 août 2015 la poste
commence peu à peu à faire passer
l'examen à des dizaines de milliers de
candidats et cela partout en france
une initiative qui devrait permettre aux
candidats d' attendre moins longtemps et
d'obtenir plus rapidement ce fameux code
de la route nous sommes allés à la
plateforme d'accueil d'industrie pardon
industrielle courrier de la poste à bois
d'arcy qui accueille trois sessions par
jour un reportage signé nicolas landry
jours d'examen du code de la route à la
plateforme industrielle courrier de la
poste à bois d'arcy les deux
examinatrices prépare l'épreuve après
avoir suivi une formation le 19 et 20
juin dernier marie-laure cumule son
poste de contrôle de la qualité du
service et cette nouvelle fonction j'ai
trouvé que c'était une opportunité pour
la poste pour donner
nouvelle image de la poste après la
constitution du dossier dans une auto
école ou à la préfecture les candidats
s'inscrivent sur le site internet de la
poste
coût d'inscription 30 euros versée à
l'entreprise publique
ils reçoivent ensuite une convocation
par mail après un premier échec
abdel passe son code pour la première
fois avec la nouvelle version l'examen
se déroule individuellement sur
tablettes avec des questions différentes
pour chaque candidat
les réponses sont envoyés au ministère
de l'intérieur c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur qui procèdent à la
correction ensuite une fois va que la
correction effet tire les candidats
reçoivent sous 48 heures or faire un
jour férié et week-end leurs résultats
par mail venu accompagner son ami abdel
ousmane a déjà son code en poche j'ai
passé à cergy-pontoise durera tant de
pas mal de temps pour voir une date
alors que mon ami à elle a passé très
rapidement
la poisse à plus de dates c'est moins
long après une heure d'épreuve l'examen
est terminée pour abdel franchement je
pouvais la tablette c'est plutôt mieux
en ce qu on a plus l'image devant nous
ouais c'est plutôt mieux que sur les
boîtiers en septembre prochain un
nouveau centre d'examen devraient ouvrir
dans une autre plateforme industrielle
courrier yvelinoise et parlons
apolitique
à présent nous allons revenir sur un
sujet qui a fait l'actualité cette année
dans notre département avec une rouille
ml bonsoir williams alors avec moi ce
soir pour parler de la fusion
départementale entre les civils et les
hauts-de-seine tout à fait fort en
souvenez vous tout a commencé en janvier
2016 le département des yvelines est
celui des hauts-de-seine avait choisi de
mutualiser leurs cérémonies
voeux pour la nouvelle année une
cérémonie qui s'est tenue au haras de
jardy dans le 92 et durant laquelle
avait été fait l'annoncé officielle du
projet de fusion des deux départements
on écoute l'interview de pierre bédier à
l'époque c'est de faire de la
mutualisation encore faisant des choses
qu on faisait chacun de notre côté mais
en les faisant ensemble ça coûtera moins
cher
voilà un exemple c'est pour ça qu'on
commence par les routes les appels
d'offres on comptera concerneront deux
départements donc forcément les
entreprises pour les avoirs seront
obligés de baisser leurs prix dès cette
mutualisation de générer des économies
qu'ils vont être affectés à modérer la
pression fiscale et à financer le
développement économique et il n'y a pas
de politique sociale possible son
développement économique
l'objectif est donc de réaliser des
économies siens exactement ce projet de
fusion c'est une conséquence des bêtes
des baisses de dotations de l'état selon
département les yvelines aurait perdu
près de 90% de sa dotation globale de
fonctionnement qui seraient passés de
145 millions d'euros en 2013 à 13
millions d'euros en 2017 soit une perte
totale de 132 millions dans son budget
en quatre ans le rapprochement des deux
territoires serait donc un moyen de
mutualiser les services et donc de
réaliser des économies pour les deux
départements
lorsque nous avons vu cet argent vient
aujourd'hui où en sommes nous de cette
fusion alors pour l'instant la fusion
n'est pas encore en fin n'est encore
qu'un projet on parlerait plus d'un
trait d'union entre les deux
départements et ce trait d'union il a
pris la forme d'un le pays
un établissement public de coordination
interdépartementale qui a été créée le
23 mars 2016 et dont patrick devidjian a
pris la présidence
on n'est pas encore dans une fusion
on est simplement dans un processus de
rapprochement
nous avons un instrument pour travailler
ensemble et déterminer ce que pourra
être dans l'avenir
une fusion si nous réussissons à la
mener à son terme nous avançons pas à
pas le pragmatisme et aussi de grande
détermination parce que nous sommes
vraiment convaincu que la région
parisienne et dans panel est en panne de
développement économique et que
l'association de ces deux départements
c'est une réponse d'intérêt général
cet établissement public de coopération
inter départementale est donc composé
des conseillers départementaux des deux
départements au total donc 88 personnes
et requins sont les premiers en action
le pays pour l'instant 2 s'est réuni que
2 fois la première pour élire son bureau
et ses différentes commissions dans
lesquelles on retrouve l'action sociale
la culture l'environnement la voirie ou
encore le développement économique
pour voir la liste complète je vous
invite à vous rendre sur le site
internet de le pays alors dans les
premières actions désormais engagé il y
à la création d'un service inter
départemental d'archéologie préventive
qui a été votée le 15 avril
on retrouve aussi pour les transports le
projet de mise en commun des services
d'entretien et d'exploitation du réseau
routier départemental
la mutualisation et l'optimisation des
achats a été elle aussi voté le 15 avril
le 30 juin dernier lors de sa deuxième
réunion le pays a voté la fusion de ces
deux sociétés mixte d'aménagement la
sem92 et yveline aménagements qui
deviennent site alios un aménageur
public au service des collectivités
ces missions ça va être de trop service
des communes en particulier et de leur
apporter toutes les compétences avec en
même temps
toute la réflexion que nous allons
conduire et qui sera une réflexion qui
sera plutôt dans une philosophie de
liberté des collectivités locales que
dans celle du la centralisation étatiste
dire est développé par grand paris
aménagements ce matin donc nous avons
pris des décisions importantes autour de
l'aménagement du territoire
l'aménagement du territoire pour être
bref simple clair c'est la construction
de logements et d'équipements la
construction de logements pour loger les
illinois les alto séquanais et les
équipements qui vont avec ses
constructions de logements également au
menu de cette dernière réunion le vote
du budget primitif 2016 et la création
d'un budget annexe un budget qualifié de
light par son président d'un montant de
445 1000 euros consacrée pour
l'essentiel à l'archéologie préventive
voilà comme le disent les deux
présidents des départements sept pays
qu'ils qualifient d'historique avance
pas à pas avec pour objectif évidemment
de réaliser des économies
une fusion totale qui n'arrivera peut
être jamais mais en tout cas un
rapprochement déjà bien engagé sujet que
nous suivrons merci beaucoup à vous
williams autre sujet parlant football à
présent le stade de la coudre était
rouge et bleu hier toute la journée
la fondation psg psg part dans offert
une journée de sport et d'amusement à 70
enfants de montigny le bretonneux
une opération mise en place par le
conseil départemental des yvelines et la
fondation du club parisien au profit
d'enfants de 6 à 12 ans pour une journée
ludique et éducative autour du football
williams elle pour ses reportages
dribbles passes tirs au but est retourné
acrobatique
aujourd'hui c'est le ballon qui a
rassemblé ses 70 jeunes au stade de la
coudre de montigny le bretonneux à
l'origine de l'opération un partenariat
entre la fondation psg et le conseil
départemental des yvelines
on a là bas chaque coup franc qui venait
arnould jeu à quatre buts
le quiz le tube ball rugby flag et c'est
un occupant ses journées on est nul
trois valeurs qui ne sont essentiels
dont le fair play le respect et la
solidarité qu'on véhicule tout au long
de la journée
à la fin de la journée des cadeaux sont
distribués aux enfants
au total ce sont cinq villes dans les
yvelines qui ont pu profiter de
l'opération grâce à la fondation psg et
500 enfants qui ont pu se révéler ce
passe d'une journée footballeurs
professionnels ont toujours en football
une soixantaine de jeunes footballeurs
âgés de 17 à 23 ans étaient réunis ce
mardi au centre technique de
clairefontaine en yvelines les sportifs
vont participer à la rentrée prochaine
un programme éducatif baptisé et du
sport academy qui mêle le football et
l'apprentissage de l'anglais en écosse
un reportage signé mickaël miro est mal
on labat partie en écosse pour
progresser en football et apprendre
l'anglais c'est l'objectif de et du
sport academy la structure créée en 2011
membre de la fédération écossaise
propose un programme de neuf mois en
totale immersion dans les villes de
glasgow et d'edimbourg
c'est un peu entre guillemets comme un
centre d'information et sont des
entraînements quotidiens
après ils sont des cours d'anglais
quotidien aussi surtout en fait c'est un
cadre et monkey très professionnel on a
des entraîneurs qui sont diplômés niveau
et fa efa efa pro qui sont d'ailleurs
des anges en footballeur professionnel
donc c'est les structures très très très
bien et très professionnelle beaucoup
d'exigence et les projets en fait c'est
mélange un peu les côté français avec le
culture écossais pour faire un vrai
mélange footballistique
cette grande aventure a débuté ce mardi
12 juillet au centre technique de
clairefontaine en yvelines avec le
premier rassemblement des joueurs
détectés par les scouts de la structure
cette année ils sont une soixantaine de
sportifs venus de france de suisse et de
belgique a participé au programme en
grève des femmes et est à la fois on
apprend l'anglais en progrès
donc c'est scolaire plus le foot qui est
ma passion et partir à l'étranger donc
voilà c'est parfois c'est l'expérience
de pouvoir vivre un an à l'étranger déjà
cassé important en plus de ça les
français on n'est pas très bon en langue
donc l'opportunité d'apprendre l'anglais
dans un pays anglophone c'est plutôt
plutôt intéressant et puis il ya
toujours le côté foot qui est notre
passion donc ça permet à côté de ça de
pouvoir pouvoir jouer notre passion quoi
les joueurs rejoindront les causes début
septembre pour débuter le championnat
lors de la saison 2015 2016 trois jours
de l'est du sport academy on signe un
contrat professionnel avec des clubs
écossais il est temps à présent de
passer à notre entretien nous avons
parlé à ce soir d'un concours de beauté
mais pas n'importe lequel celui de miss
et mister en ile-de-france pour nous en
parler en plateau avec nous cécile
aveline colo du comité miss et mister en
ile de france
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté à
notre invitation alors ce concours va se
dérouler le 17 juillet 2016 à 14 heures
sur la commune de bouaye l'heure si ce
n'est pas une nouveauté car il existe
depuis 2013 c'est bien ça alors le
concours en lui-même a été créé en 2002
2012 pardon excusez moi par
l'association entre 4 ou et depuis 2013
il est ouvert donc aux hommes au départ
il était ouvert uniquement aux femmes
alors qu'elle est un peu l'objectif de
ce concours
l'objectif c'est d'aider les personnes à
s'accepter soi-même par rapport à leur
handicap d'ouvrir aussi un concours pas
uniquement
aux personnes valides mais aux personnes
donc invalide
sachant que le handicap peut être
physique mais aussi il peut être aussi
inaperçu pour certaines personnes ça
aussi une manière de lutter contre les
préjugés père ceux de montrer des
personnes handicapées autrement
totalement
on a énormément de mal à faire accepter
les personnes handicapées pourquoi parce
que peut-être une peur d'eux mais aussi
éventuellement problèmes d'accessibilité
parce que quand nous avons une personne
qui est en chaise roulante a plus de mal
je veux dire accéder les entreprises
sachant que c'est pour ça que
notre association entre 4 eu 4 ou par
non se développe de plus en plus au
niveau national et veut faire changer
cette mentalité
alors comment ça va un peu se dérouler
ce concours alors déjà on a une
préparation au niveau de la salle la
salle communale donc que la mairie doit
dire si nous avons offert gratuitement
donc c'est surtout un super geste de la
part donc de monsieur philippe benassaya
le maire de bois d'arcy de l'équipe
associatif et événementiel donc deux
jours de préparatifs en donc la
préparation de la salle aller chercher
donc les différents cadeaux de nos
prestataires faire aussi donc des
panneaux d'affichage pour les personnes
qui vont venir par le train par la route
au niveau des communes avoisinantes et
puis surtout préparer les candidates
parce que nous avons donc énormément de
bénévoles que ça ça comme un vrai
concours de beauté etc c'est la
préparation il ya des filets aussi je ne
sais pas oui il ya un défilé donc nous
accueillons donc les candidats à partir
de 14h jusqu'à 15 heures et le début
donc de l'élection a lieu à 15 heures
avec eux bien sûr l'élection est donc
la personne qui sera élu en tant que
miss ses trois dauphines
le mister et ses deux dauphins partir de
18h 18h30
ils ont peut-être à des épreuves un
message à faire passer
comment ils sont aussi jugés parce
qu'ils le seront là cette soirée alors
ils seront jugés surtout sur des
critères entre autres je parlais donc
d'élocution de leur parcours
et puis surtout qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
faire dégager en ayant été élue miss et
mister leur valeur bien sûr et puis
surtout on attend bien sûr de nos futurs
ambassadeurs de la beauté et de
l'élégance et de la tolérance de
s'engager auprès donc de leur comité
mais aussi auprès de l'association entre
4 ou sachant que l'association entre 4
ou a été créée donc en 2002 par notre
présidente
puissent-ils vignerons donc association
qui est situé en isère à grenoble et
donc nous avons besoin surtout de
montrer que ce n'est pas un seul
concours de beauté
c'est un concours d'engagement d'une
acceptation de soi par les candidats
vous avez des candidats aussi entre
parenthèses qui ont besoin qui ont
besoin de prouver à leur famille et à
leurs amis à leurs collègues qui sont là
qu'ils existent et qu'ils ont besoin ou
sont surtout d'être aimé c'est un
challenge pour chaque personne parce que
je pense que j'avais peut-être rencontré
déjà les gens qui vont se présenter
un challenge pour eux justement de
participer à ce concours alors moi au
niveau du comité miss tandis ile de
france je suis partenaires sponsors et
président du jury et je n'ai pas le
droit de rencontrer les candidats
nous avons surtout
1 comment ça dérègle donc ce n'est pas
moi qui les rencontrent et je les
rencontrerai mois à partir de 14 heures
vous avez des retours des précédentes
éditions
totalement donc à l'heure actuelle notre
miss ont dit ile-de-france et fatima
barbant qui est souvent en déplacement
donc pour montrer qu'elles sont
élections bien sûr ce qu'elle dégage
c'est d'engagement aussi associatif à
côté c'est une maman donc c'est une
femme qui est pour moi accompli et donc
nous cherchons surtout le côté là la
femme accomplie et l'homme aussi alors
leur rôle
une fois qu'ils sont élus à miss et
mister andy ile de france et ce qu'ils
ont un rôle d'ambassadeur auprès voilà
vous disais d'associations ou peut-être
pour faire un club bouger les choses
pour la cause des personnes en situation
d'handicap
alors à l'heure actuelle donc nous le
comité miss et mister andy ile-de-france
se bouge énormément pour faire donc
valoir ce concours dans les régions dans
22 régions
nous avons aussi des partenaires comme
vous un tv fil 78 qui nous permettent
entre parenthèses d'en parler nous avons
les commerçants les commerçants nous
avons des partenaires des partenaires
cadeau ça peut être une mare par exemple
je parle de la marque ce thème fort qui
a dit oui tout de suite
donc le magasin qui se trouve à villebon
sur yvette
nous avons des partenaires aussi des
artistes parce que je suis aussi entre
parenthèses de dans le domaine de l'art
donc j'ai des amis où je leur en ai
parlé ils ont dit oui tout de suite pour
cette cause
donc il y avait dans une récolte de
fonds aussi dans cette soirée justement
à poisat station pour les personnes non
pas du tout pas du tout c'est on offre
on offre bien sûr des cadeaux donc par
exemple je vous parlais d'artistes
j'ai une artiste peintre qui travaille
pour le barreau donc des yvelines donc
de versailles qui va offrir trois de ses
tableaux j'ai une autre collègue du
tribunal de grande instance de
versailles qui va offrir des créations
de bijoux
on a par exemple des partenaires
restauration énormément de partenaires
qui m'ont suivi sur la commune donc de
fontenay-le-fleury donc qu'ils vont
offrir l'accueil des candidats dimanche
matin par des viennoiseries ou alors
pour le pot de l'amitié à 18 heures se
trouvait public est important pour cette
élection vous accueillez vraiment tout
le monde tout le monde est invité
justement à venir voir ce concours alors
ce concours est gratuit il est ouvert à
tout le monde
nous avons besoin de la voix du public
pour élire nos futurs ambassadeurs donc
de la beauté de l'élégance et de la
tolérance
un dernier mot peut-être je vois que
vous n'êtes pas venu les mains vides et
notamment sur votre association
halo 4 je voulais parler du diadème de
la nation c'est un appel à textes que
j'ai lancée auprès de mes amis poètes
dompter des cinq continents qui ont
répondu oui et donc nous avons fait
publier donc le diadème de la nation
pourquoi pour aider l'association entre
4 ou et surtout les comités donc dans
leurs frais fixes parce qu'il ya des
frais fixes bien sûr et surtout donc ce
recueil donc collectif va être offert à
chaque fois aux candidats c'est à dire à
tous les candidats les candidats qui se
sont inscrits voilà très bien merci
merci beaucoup alors je le rappelle le
concours se déroule le 17 juillet 2016
donc ce week-end 14 heures sur la
commune de bois d'arcy voilà vous avez
les informations qui passe à l'écran
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le
facebook également pour avoir plus
d'information merci avez vous fait et si
vous ne partez pas encore en vacances
que vous restez dans la région vous
demandez certainement que faire avec vos
enfants cet été à rambouillet la
bergerie nationale a lancé ces jeux
d'été la semaine dernière d agréer
vacances pour s'occuper des animaux
découvrir à l'agroécologie ou encore
déguster du lait fermier camille lambert
vous emmène à la bergerie
si meringue est aussi populaire c'est
qu'elle est habituée à être au contact
des enfants
depuis plusieurs années la bergerie
nationale organise ses agriva cance de
nombreuses animations sont proposées
tous les jours durant l'été ici le coin
talent j'aime bien venir à la ferme nous
parce que j'aime bien deux nés à manger
aux animaux et j'aime bien les caresser
et regarder ça permet aux familles de
rentrer à l'intérieur de cet espace pour
pouvoir s'approcher au plus près des
animaux puisque c'est aussi ce qu'ils
recherchent
en venant ici c'est de pouvoir approcher
les animaux et pouvoir les caresser et
les toucher le plus possible piscine de
paille tracts au cross et découverte de
la ferme en calèche les jeux d'été se
veulent également ludique
nouveauté cette année une visite sur
l'agroécologie pour sensibiliser les
plus jeunes
depuis mai 2016 la bergerie nationale
s'est lancé dans l'agriculture
biologique décidé d'adapter un discours
assez compliquée avec des mois c'est
compliqué sur l'agriculture biologique
de l'adapter à un public d'enfants donc
d'expliquer notre projet d'établissement
qui est un projet orienté autour de
l'agroécologie donc de l'agriculture
durable
après avoir observé les vaches dans les
champs direction la salle de traite et
pour les curieux une dégustation de lait
fermier mais les avis sont partagés
c'est bizarre
d'abord les toits avec des lingettes et
apprennent ont les traits avec des
machines lamache les jeux d'été de la
bergerie nationale continue jusqu'au 31
août
meringue est prête à vous accueillir et
une dernières informations avant de
refermer ce journal
saint-quentin-en-yvelines engage une
réflexion large visant à mettre en place
un projet de territoire durable et
concerté ça s'appelle sky de demain et
jusqu'à fin octobre une grande
concertation est lancée avec l'opération
dites le en images ce qui me plaît ce
qui me plaît pas sur territoire afin de
préparer son projet l'agglomération a
besoin de vous elle collecte des photos
et des vidéos du 1er juillet jusqu'au 31
octobre 2016 alors l'idée est simple
c'est de permettre à tous les
utilisateurs du territoire habitants
salariés
étudiant d'exprimer leur ressenti sur la
vie à 50 ans divine grâce à vos photos
ou vidéos vous donner ainsi votre avis
vous dit ce qu'il vous plaît à 50 ans
deviner ce qui ne vous plaît pas dans
les 12 communes que vous voulez voir
changer perdurer ou encore être amélioré
dans l'avenir vous pouvez envoyer vos
réalisations 1 par mail à l'adresse sky
demain robin à sky point fr ou encore
via les réseaux sociaux twitter
instagram facebook en mentionnant le mot
clé #skype demain et en expliquant
brièvement votre chat votre choix
pardon c'est la fin de cette édition je
remercie de nous avoir suivis c'était
pour moi le dernier set 8 le journal de
cette saison j'étais ravi de le
présenter du lundi au jeudi je tenais
ainsi à vous remercier de votre fidélité
également parfois de vos retours
je souhaite également remercier à tout
toute la rédaction tous les journalistes
pour leur travail ainsi que les monteurs
qui sont aussi nos réalisateurs la régie
également notre infographiste mais les
également l'assistante de direction
ghislaine bladou toutes ces personnes
qui ont permis au journal de se faire à
chaque jour et personnes qui ont tout
fait pour eux également proposer une
information de qualité tout de suite
vous retrouvez manip ok pour le dernier
numéro de kiosques que votre magazine
culturel sur saint quentin en yvelines
vendredi vous retrouvez à wilfrid
berrichi pour le dernier journal de la
saison et quant à moi je vous
retrouverai une dernière fois pour le 7
8 8e spéciale et et je vous souhaite
donc une excellente soirée et de très
bonnes vacances au revoir